hello everyone
welcome to rational science
the only site on the internet that does
science
does physics right you might say hold it
you're the only one who does
science uh yeah
and that's because we redefined science
sometime back
20 years ago okay and you don't have to
agree
but the way we do it in science we don't
lift our hands and vote
okay well the way we do it in science is
we define
we have to define what science is and
we have to defend that definition when
someone attacks it
and proposes a better mousetrap right
and so we define science not as
mathematics not as description
not as prediction okay not as
observation
not as measurement we define science as
explanation you have to have an
explanation to have a theory
and science is a body of theories
whether you believe in the theories
is irrelevant we don't believe in
science in science we explain them so
that you
understand them and they better be
rational
and there are criteria for that as well
okay and so
today uh as usual we're going to define
divide
our lecture in three parts first part is
going to deal with extinction the
extinction of man
primarily and uh the second part is
going to deal with the
review of what we did last time
well i hope everybody's listening
i just received a message from youtube
saying not enough video
that is weird uh did you send me the i
got the url
because i can check it you send this to
my email
uh yeah yeah you got it i'm gonna go
check it
see if it's right give us a second here
guys uh i think it's okay
because in iceland i had the same
problem but it was choppy here i don't
see it choppy yet
so give us a second let's make sure
we're we're okay
let give me a a message if you think
that
um you're not receiving
a good stream okay let's wait a second
here
says youtube is not receiving enough
video to maintain smooth streaming
so i don't know what's going on
i hope everybody can hear me right i
hope everybody can see me right
let me know otherwise you sound good to
me okay
i don't know what's going on i received
a message from youtube saying they're
not receiving
yeah then i don't know what that error
is all about
okay let me continue then thank you guys
i don't know why that message came up
false alarm jesus great scare the hell
out of me there again
okay anyways um we're going to divide it
in three parts
and the first part we're going to do
extinction especially the extinction of
man
and past extinctions as well you know
mass extinctions
make it sound like we already died and
other extinctions that happened
and i'm going to move into a review of
what we did last month
which wasn't too great because i was in
iceland and
again i had all this streaming problem
but there was really bad
and and then i'm going to move into the
questions people asked and then people
can ask questions today based on that
material or anything you want to ask
so let's move on to what uh
extinction okay let's start there uh
just briefly what is it about for those
of you who are new
who haven't been around here around this
channel
uh we're saying that we are the last
generation of humans
on earth and no that is not a joke uh
we're serious about it we're saying we
are the last generation of humans on
earth
is it because an asteroid is coming
towards us are we going to die because
of some disease or
global warming global warming or
something no no
we say that all mass extinctions all of
them including ours
the upcoming extinction of man happened
in the same way
and ours will happen in that same way as
well and that is the collapse
of the global economy once uh
the economy collapses uh we have
no one produces food and no one trades
food because food will be the only thing
of value so you're saying the economy of
the dinosaurs went out their dino
dollars
uh well we'll get to say someone had a
question along those lines
we'll get to that in a second when the
jokes become reality
uh but yeah so uh we're saying that
there's gonna be a
global economic collapse and
when not if but when that happens it's
the end of man
and i think uh it's gonna happen
relatively soon
i don't have a crystal ball i can't give
you a date i don't know when it's gonna
happen
here we are when we talk about the
mechanism we're interested in the theory
whether you believe in the theory or not
well that's that's your
prerogative okay okay so i started with
some homework
or ended up sorry with some homework the
other day and the homework was like this
it said
uh and i cover your face i hope you
don't you don't get offended by that
uh why did the fauna and the seas
disappear at the same time as the
animals
on land uh which occasions
it doesn't matter what extinction
whether you take the um
but to clarify in every extinction there
were land
and sea and air and
air land and sea just like the marines
and the army yeah
uh so we had air land and sea and all
these animals
more or less all these species all these
orders because we're talking about
really the big five the big five mass
extinctions
all these orders disappeared almost
completely
very some in in some instances a couple
cross the line
and they died shortly afterwards
anywheres anyways but
in general terms uh when the mass
extinction happened
the animals on land in the air and in
the seas
died more or less at the same time maybe
there were a few thousand years
difference
okay but the issue here is that from a
geological point of view
you can say that they died at the same
time you cannot tell the difference in
the layer of rock
you know uh if there was a thousand or
two thousand years you know water
right they counted all that in millions
of years almost okay
so maybe there was a difference between
the animal and the
land and the one in the seas no problem
but they more or less
basically in general terms they died
more or less at the same time and also
to clarify it wasn't all
animals on land it was specific ones
all the ones in the ocean you need to
explain selectivity
and why did some die and not others but
the issue is if you can figure out
listen if you can figure out why they
died more or less at the same time
you have discovered
an important clue to the cause or the
mechanism
of mass extinction okay so that's the
point of the homework
well one guy gave it a try and he came
up with this
how many people tried to answer this or
what well no just one guy
so far i like this answer he says the
force we experience
known as gravity killed the dinos by
increasing weight upon their limbs to
ridiculous quantities
they were crushed by variable laws not
so
constants of physics okay
no problem so you you told me how the
big dinos
died okay they were so big they gravity
crushed them that's kind of a good
okay try let's let's go let's go with
this real quick that would explain why
the big ones died in the small don't
okay
let's go with that one but now uh that's
uh
you know uh brachiosaur uh people know
it's brontosaur from uh
fred flintstone jurassic park or
whatever
but uh then you have that other fellow
there he was in the water he was a
reptile
and his name was the mosasaur okay he
was a reptile that was in the water
disappeared around the same time again
you know maybe a thousand years
difference whatever
and the gravity killed him as well in
the water
okay it turns out that you know he ate
ammonites
and ammonites also disappeared around
the same time
and ammonites ate the plankton you know
for a minifera
uh diatoms and those disappeared as well
and those were tiny little things
uh did gravity make those disappear as
well so it's not
big it's not just size they killed them
but nice try anyways yeah
okay uh no problem in considering all
the possibilities but then
you know one of the things you got to do
is uh be a critic of your own theory
you know and it's very hard to do that
because people have these strong
feelings about their theories about
their beliefs and their
whatever you know the way i think it's
hard to do if you're actually trying to
get to the bottom of it
it's hard to do if you just want to be
right
yeah but it's it's one of those things
that when you grew up with something
for example for many years like
christianity in my case
atheism it's very hard to to get rid of
that
it really is you know so uh it's one of
those things which where you
sometimes learn the hard way like i've
learned the hard way
but it'd be nice if you know you
criticize your theory before you get to
a point where you know
you really break down and say oh my god
i believe that all this nonsense throw
so many years that's the good thing if
you don't criticize it someone else will
you'll find out absolutely okay next
issue
fellow says uh
he says the ice age killed the animals
and there you see all these animals poor
they're in
in the snow and in the ice in the
glaciers i just came from iceland and
boy it's full of glaciers and there's
the ice ice age up there hasn't stopped
yet over there
is that a dalmatian dino
which one the one in the bottom no
that's like a
t-rex yeah but it's white and black with
like spots yeah yeah they paint them any
color they want you know
but the issue is uh did they die did
these uh
dinosaurs die because of climate change
i mean we have climate change so much in
the news lately and people talk a lot
about it
the the politicians you know they have
all these international meetings they
talk about climate change
uh there's this norwegian girl what's
her name remember
and she talks about climate change so
everybody's into this climate change
issue because you know they go to the
north pole and they see
you know the glaciers melting and the
poor little bears sinking in
you know polar bears sinking into the
water uh
so you know people talk a lot about
climate change
did climate change ever kill a single
species on planet earth
in the history of life on earth i would
say i'm saying never did
one or the other would it would just got
too hot for him but then they would have
just evolved with them
or go to somewhere else oh yeah maybe
not
you know it's one of those things that
when the going gets rough
or when the going gets hot uh
the rough get moving you know so i'm
sure the species all just adapted to
whatever the temperature was
uh temperature goes a little slower
maybe an evolution
or maybe just about but certainly moving
to a better climate is
a faster way to elude you know the
incoming cold for example i don't think
there was an issue of hot but there is
an issue of cold at least uh
for past extinctions at least that's
what people analyze
okay go uh with the next question or
comment uh where is it here
one guy says the dinosaurs are gone
because they ran out of money
hey that's my theory don't steal it from
me hold on i'm gonna go check the stream
again
uh what's up
buffering stops okay so there is a
problem
aha now i say i show that it shows an
excellent connection maybe it was
temporary
okay maybe it was temporary uh keep
giving me messages we'll find out if
it's any good uh
uh my son went there to check to see if
our connection is good but right now i
show it's good from youtube youtube is
saying that i get
a good connection okay maybe it was a
glitch for a moment
yeah sometimes okay uh i think it's all
right now we'll
play it by ear okay something we got to
leave live with
i never had that problem here in
frankfurt but i did have it in iceland
because the hotel
everybody was uh crowded in the hotel we
were all
under quarantine and everybody was using
the internet so i couldn't use it
i couldn't even get on the internet
sometimes did you tell them it was an
emergency uh yeah
okay okay thank you uh anyways uh
dinosaurs are gone because they ran
out of money uh in a way yeah
in fact i think they called it the uh in
those days you know in the days of the
dinosaurs
they called it the um uh what is it
no they called it the bite coin
[Laughter]
service fighting okay uh but in a way
you're right
you know in a way uh yeah uh i think uh
it's their money their currency was food
all animals uh need food okay among them
an animal called human okay the humans
we need food and you know people are not
aware but
everything we do every day everything we
produce whether we produce something
tangible like a computer
or a car or whatever or we produce uh
some service some abstraction out there
everything we produce on earth
serves only one purpose and that is to
trade it
or exchange it for food so that we can
live
one more day whether you're bill gates
or bill gatey it doesn't matter
uh you trade it for food you could say
we all we're all sick and we all need
medicine
yeah but medicine if if if you're not
sick
i'm equating it with well yeah in that
sense yeah we need rice
to yeah i'm sick with this stomach
bug where i need to eat rice medicine or
meat medicine or whatever just to keep
living one more day yeah food you need
you don't need money
you don't need a computer you don't need
a car
i need a computer but but what you
you don't even need love you can be a
hit herman out there in the mountain for
all we know
and certainly if you're an old uh
individual okay uh you probably need
less love and more uh
healthcare more doctors than love
but what we all need is food we can't
live without food with
without water air areas is free i think
so far nobody's bottled that
uh water they bottled it but we can
still get some from the river
if you have a clean enough river they do
have clean rivers in iceland
uh not here in frankfurt i wouldn't
drink for the mine from the mountain
river
but what we all need is food okay
so uh yeah the currency of the you can
say the currency of the
dinosaurs they didn't trade okay they
didn't invent trade
but they needed to eat what they had
what does it mean for their cur for
their currency to run out
well they're currency big terms their
currency like all our currency
is food ultimately we take it for
granted
we take it for granted that you know
that oh food
i can get it at the corner uh
supermarket
and it's like we don't pay attention to
food first because it's quite cheap
uh in general you know i mean whatever
money you make
if you're working whatever money you
make you just go to the store and you
buy it
it's like you take it for granted but it
turns out that you know
someone produced it for money someone
distributed for money
and if money is no more for whatever
reason god comes in there and wins this
magic wand and
money is no more that's it for man
because no one produces it or
distributes it
so the issue is that all mass
extinctions happen because the food
chain
collapsed in our case it involves money
in other animals it didn't it doesn't
involve money but
again you know it's uh one of those
things without food
for certain you will die okay well what
does it mean that there that the
dinosaur's
money ran out well he says he was
criticizing my theory saying
so what happened now did money run out
what is the theory though well the
theory is that food ran out but he's
saying
because i'm saying it's an economic
collapse he said oh what happened did
money run out
well yeah in a way it's the money that
they use and it was food
and it turns out that our money is
really food as well but we are not
aware of that because we have these
bills or maybe even bitcoin or some
abstraction that we trade and we always
do it for food
ultimately i mean you can buy computers
you can buy cars you can buy whatever
you want services
but ultimately what we produce
everything on earth is to
eat and live one more day okay so keep
that in mind
uh those are the what i call the vitals
vitals okay
uh air water food sleep
temperature sex for some people isn't
that like the maslow's hierarchy of
yeah those are the absolute necessities
and that's where mother nature
harps on that's how she produces
extinction not through asteroids or
volcanoes or anything like that okay
okay next issue uh let's move on here
uh you have it backwards oh i'm so sorry
okay
production creates money money does not
create production
production creates money because money
is a representation
of production as a side note we'll
answer all the chat questions at the end
yeah i said that on the money money
money okay
yeah okay so um what's the answer to
this fellow
here it is we can get this thing up
there okay
and is that production does indeed
create money no problem there
however when humans invented money
production
preceded trade first you had to have
uh uh production you had to produce
something tangible
in those days originally so that you
could trade it for something else
so there was a production and it was
production for production and that's
that was the exchange but today this day
and age right
without money we have no production
if god comes in with this magic wand for
whatever reason and eliminates all
money and we do not believe anymore in
money for whatever reason
then no one produces anything money is
what keeps the whole chain
of our existence alive so we're saying
that
it used to be that we produced first
like
let's say way back then in
hunter-gatherer times or maybe after the
agricultural times
production came first and then since we
had production then we invented money to
organize the production
but now it's kind of you could say
gotten out of hand where now we only
produce
to make the money yeah now with the cart
before the horse
yeah yeah things kind of changed around
because now we produce only to get
money in those days it was you produce
something to maybe to get food
or to get something tangible i mean
maybe a guy traded corn for a table for
all i know you know or
some uh blacksmith uh produced a sword
and
gave it to you for some wheat or
whatever but today we we produce
things and even we're not even producing
things we're producing abstractions
and uh we trade them for money which is
another abstraction
and why because we want to have money
because with money you can buy
the world okay so that's we've changed
that around
and the question is you know today we're
completely in an abstract world
okay another issue uh here it is we
didn't talk about torque or light yet
about whether i'm just answering some of
the questions oh yeah yeah we'll get
there
uh we'll get to your questions at the
end okay
china is becoming the number one world
economy it's happening right now as we
speak
it will be common knowledge by the end
of the 2030s
if we ever make it that far okay china
is not going to take over the world okay
we agree there okay
it will be the financial capital of the
world as it shifts from west to east
due to the decline of western republics
devolving
into oligarchies of career politicians
and their cronies
uh that's a lot of politics okay and uh
all i can tell you is i'll give you my
five cents worth
and that's that yeah i agree that maybe
china
might overtake the united states the
west whatever you want to call it
economically but you have to remember
first that china depends
on the west for its growth that's one
issue
the other issue is that even if it takes
over
economically i doubt very much
the united states will allow china to
overtake it
militarily okay that's an important
point to keep in mind because that's
taking us to a point where there's a
crisis
where china maybe expands economically
to a point that the united states is
worried about that so much that it
creates a
false flag and incident like i showed
the other day and
there's a war we have not a cold war we
have a
hot war and just keep that in mind uh
there could be more involved with
china becoming an empire than just
economics
okay there could be military solutions
okay moving on here another issue
that i want to raise and that's this one
and that's uh that i always say you got
to deal with
extinction 101 before you touch
extinction 102
at least you know you got to show me
that you know something about extinction
mass extinctions especially before you
talk about the extinction of man
because the extinction of man is one
instance of
mass extinction if that's how you think
it's going to happen which is what i
think at least
and so first you got to tell me how past
extinctions happen what is the mechanism
and again the homework helps you there
if you can tell me
why the animals on land disappeared at
this more or less at the same time as
those
in the water uh you got a good clue of
how they disappeared why what caused
their extinction that's one issue the
other one is you gotta explain
selectivity
why on land itself some animals
disappear and otherwise
and others stand be stay behind okay so
just keep all that in mind we do like uh
for you to answer
101 before you answer 102 101 is
mass extinction 102 is
human extinction it's a special case of
mass extinction
and talking about that here's one fellow
who says
extinction 101 never happened we are
still here
uh so i think he he confused it yeah i
think he was referring to 102 apparently
if you think
he's saying that there were no such
thing as mass extinctions and they all
just evolved into us
yeah and and uh and that's a lot of
people especially religious people they
don't believe that there were dinosaurs
and that
those extinctions ever happened uh in
fact originally when
george kuvir and some of these other or
the
founders of paleontology came up with
paleontology they essentially started
the discipline known as
uh paleontology what happened was uh you
know when they showed this to some of
the religious folk in those days we're
talking about the
1800s okay the early
1800s these people would look at those
bones and they didn't understand
anything about it and said well that
looks like an elephant
it had arthritis so it's a big elephant
yeah so uh they said
just an elephant that died that's all it
is really spiky teeth
yeah so uh you know uh some
religious folk especially uh traditional
religious folk who believe that the
earth is maybe 7 000 years old or
old or 11 000 years old or whatever
calculation they've got out there
they don't think that there were such
animals as dinosaurs
and so you can't talk to them about a
mass extinction because they don't even
accept the
assumption okay the original theory or
assumption that led to that
okay okay and final uh
comment on extinction here it is uh says
is read pottinger's cats
to learn more about genetics and
degeneration
it can be reversed and pottinger proved
it
so he's saying that genetics essentially
can be reversed that's what he's saying
uh well let's find out this is my answer
to him okay and it goes like this
never use the word proof in science
proof means that you believe
something or someone believes something
so we don't use the word proof in
science and science we explain so that
you understand
whether it's proof to you it's been
proven to you whether you believe it
doesn't concern science at all then
pottinger did not
prove you can reverse genetics
specifically species
genetics in other words genetics at the
species level okay
and then uh without going too far we
have some people saying that
pottinger had an unscientific theory
says in 1985 pottinger's results were
criticized for lacking scientific
validity by
these couple people here uh commented
that pottinger's study was
overloaded with subjective observations
and generalizations that render it
unscientific his overall inference
was cooking meat made it unhealthy and
healthful
and helpful for cats is contradicted by
the fact that all commercial
canned foods are cooked cat foods are
cooked
okay so uh some people don't agree with
that
what he did what uh this fellow did was
scientific
it was improved to them so it was
important and so these are so-called
experts i mean if you believe
in uh in some of these uh experts or
whatever again
it's got to do with proof and all we
have are differences
of opinion out there and i don't have a
problem with differences of opinion as
long as the guy puts out a theory and
says well i don't like your mouse trap
mine is better fine
no problem we listen to these two guys
and everyone
goes home goes to this dark basement and
reaches his own conclusions
that part is religion belief all we are
interested in science is the explanation
do you understand it
that's where science ends what continues
is religion
okay let me briefly go over in fact i
have to go briefly over it
because there wasn't much material in
may because i had so much problems in
iceland uh with the
transmission okay so what was uh may all
about well it was about this
okay here's the summary okay let me
start with the summary so that we're all
on the same page
holy geometry some call it sacred
geometry
what's safety yeah it really does
amazing holding geometry has no place in
science
well here it is i mean i'll put a
picture so that you know what
holy geometry sacred geometry is all
about
no here it is okay here's people praying
to the holy geometry some people
look at these and they see meaning in
them the one on the right
blue one there uh well that's the
mandelbrot set
okay they if you keep expanding upon it
you
see more and more of the same thing over
and over and over again
it's a question of observe it's an
observer related phenomenon
where you focus closer and closer and
closer and you
you get these patterns that are
supposedly mathematically created
okay again nothing to do with physics
but people get
hypnotized by these patterns and they
say oh i'm gonna pray
they don't pray to god they play to the
cube yes like
isn't this essentially numerology yeah
it is in a way and they call it holy
geom
i'm sorry sacred geometry you know and
uh
so we don't care too much about that
okay not part of science they use
these things in like aesthetics too like
the golden ratio
yeah and they're making things like that
yeah and things that are things that are
appeasing to the human nature i guess
i don't know or they look at you know
three sixes and they put it on the
head of the devil or whatever i mean you
know they have all these
weird things these are superstitions
that's all they are
okay uh next issue um
uh uh what is it a
black well yeah i'm praying to the cube
instead of the cross
uh a black hole is not an object okay
what is a black hole it's a singularity
surrounding which is a
concept a mathematical concept it's
known as a singularity
no volume uh infinite density it's a
point what is a point zero dimensional
location okay et cetera non-dimensional
location actually
okay so uh black hole is a singularity
surrounded by an event horizon
a region of influence you could call it
okay concept surrounded by a concept
there you go uh to summarize right
therefore it does not qualify as a
figure for the purposes of geometry it's
not an object it's not a thing
there's no such thing like one of like
the black hole
uh and aristotle uh really followed by
mr euclid let me
get that for a second here so we can see
you aristotle followed by euclid what
did euclid say well he says that
an object is that which has a boundary
and what is the boundary of boundary is
that it ends in an object it sounds like
he's trying to say
well he's talking about a circular he
has uh he's got a circular
set of definitions but that's that which
has a boundary sounds like he was
defining it as that which has shape
yeah yeah it is and that is uh that is
and
if he would have stopped there he would
have been okay but then he said well let
me define what shape is
let's define what a boundary is and what
he says a boundary is
the end of an object the end of a shape
well you're not supposed to define shape
because again
and people sometimes have trouble with
especially people whose religion gets
destroyed by the definition of object
they have a problem with this what is
the problem the problem is we do
not have to define the word shape in
science
or in physics what we need to know is
the difference between or distinguish
between
shape motion c touch
mass volume which are the the choices
what what choice what criterion
are you going to choose to define the
word object for the purposes of physics
are you going to say that which moves
that which has location
that which has mass that which you can
see that which you can touch
or are you well yeah and something you
can't see i mean i can't see
uh i cannot see the table that i have in
my
head so is the word table an object
okay so we have a problem there yeah we
have to define it in such a way that
we encompass all
objects in the universe the words that
represent objects
and for that there is only one criterion
and that is shape
you want to know what shape is go to
kindergarten and find out they'll tell
you what shape
the kids will tell you what the
difference between a cube and a sphere
is
okay okay and uh so let's continue here
the other issue is a quantum electron
is not an object a quantum quark is not
an object quantum gluon
is not an object if the quantum hydrogen
atom
is made of electrons quarks and gluons
quarks and gluons making the proton and
the neutron by the way
then the qm the quantum mechanics atom
is not an object it's not a figure is
not a part of geometry
but they use the word point they talk
about the um
what is it the electron being a point
particle an elementary particle
a fundamental particle okay and
uh so here is let me show you that
here it is this is the definition that
you find out there
okay what is an electron are generally
thought to be elementary particles
because they have no
known components or substructures not
made of anything right and what is an
elementary particle or fundamental
particle
is a subatomic uh particle with no
currently known substructure it is not
composed of
other particles we're currently known
for that's for job security
yeah yeah we're still we're still
fascinated
still trying to find uh what all this
stuff is right
okay so this is the problem the problem
is that uh
what do we have uh today from quantum
mechanics uh
electrons uh point particle elementary
particle fundamental
particle so is the gluon which
mediates the strong force between quarks
which three of which constitute the
proton
also neutrons by the way two ups one
down two downs one up
whatever it doesn't matter the point is
you get three point particles
mediated by countless gluons which are
point particles
and what orbits them is a point particle
and they're all zero dimensional no
volume
elementary particles not made of smaller
particles meaning they're
the the ultimate you know that's where
the buck stops that we know of
that we know of that means it gives them
job security to find out what they're
made of
and for that they say well you need a an
accelerator the size of the orbit of
pluto so good luck with that whenever we
build that one i don't know how many
pesos that's going to cost us
okay so let's move on to the questions
that um
people made
okay so let's go with the first one
and then we'll get to the questions uh
real time here sorry
it takes a long time but i do wanna
answer questions that people make that
follow us and that
uh are on topic even if they throw
stones and
uh brought eggs in my face no problem
sometimes i just worry that we answer it
too
quickly maybe we do what we can but the
time we have okay
this is not a 24-hour show sometimes to
answer a question
like for the person to really understand
you got to go away yeah yeah
and sometimes i turn those into lectures
because i realize that you need a little
more uh comprehensive answer okay
okay so one file says what do you think
of category theory
what the hell is category theory well
briefly it's a category is embarrassing
this is one fell that wrote this on the
internet okay
uh embarrassingly simple concept a
category consists of
objects and arrows that go between them
okay so you see objects there aren't two
arrows that go between them okay what is
this guy talking about what the hell is
this
says that's why categories are so easy
to represent pictorially
okay an object can be drawn as a circle
or a point
and an arrow is an arrow okay that's
very
enlightening okay but the essence of a
category is
composition or you or if you prefer the
essence of composition
is a category great learned a lot so far
arrows compose so if you have an arrow
from object a to object b
and another arrow for magic object b to
c
then there must be an arrow there
composition that goes from a to c what
is he talking about
what's the context uh yeah well this can
be used they say for physics for
programming
uh they've got mathematics there's a lot
of fields that
use this notion of category theory uh
but let's continue i'll try to get to
some of these points in category theory
there you can see
if there's an error going from a to b an
arrow will come from b to c
then there must be an error going from c
a to c okay
uh okay sounds like stamp collecting
yeah so far we have not explained
anything all we have if anything is a
description
okay this is the method to categorize
yeah so let's see
first what these objects that this guy
was talking about here's the objects
okay
uh did i get that right yeah okay and so
these are the objects okay
the objects are right there in the
center center i
circle them or you know put a red square
around them
sets groups uh mathematical groups okay
uh spaces you know uh
vector spaces it says smooth uh
measurable spaces manifolds you know
what is all this all these are these are
called these are the objects
so what are they talking about what are
they talking about math that's what
they're talking about
objects of math mathematical objects
what the hell are mathematical objects
but this is what they're talking about
and so here's my answer to
that okay so that we can cut through the
rubbish okay here it is let me put it on
my side this time
or i'll cover your face you don't mind
uh oh that's cheating yeah
okay so this is category theory okay in
my
first of all it's not a theory theory is
an explanation
not a description what these people do
are described
what and how uh they describe
mathematically
they're not talking about objects real
lifestyles they're talking about
mathematical objects what is a
mathematical object
it's a concept that the mathematicians
turned into an object or treats
like an object and he moves around he
puts arrows i say oh a goes to b
or c no no it could not have gone to b
or c because both
a and b and b and c are concepts
they're tied about what what were the
objects groups sets
spaces manifolds what the hell are those
yeah i don't know what those
please draw it i want to see if there's
a pile of apples
no no no what they do is they represent
them like this guy said at the beginning
uh they represent them with circles or
with objects
so they represent love with a heart
and they point an arrow from heart to
head to mind or to
head or whatever and they say oh i've
united these two
objects no no a heart maybe but not a
love you know you can't you can't
uh join love with mind sounds like it's
like
this language and they do that they use
they say you use this
but if we're talking about coding then
if we're just talking about the actual
objects it's the hardware
yeah but they're not yeah what they're
talking about again that's the actual
object right
as like mathematical yeah there's no
such thing as a mathematical object
that's just the concept
that we extract out of the hardware yeah
the hardware is doing a lot of complex
stuff we don't talk about the hardware
exactly
which flip which zero which one even the
zeros and ones don't count
it's we're talking about like like where
the electricity is going in the circuits
that's the actual
thing that's the actual physics and
objects that were
that are being represented on screen
right but the concepts if i say a equals
three on
on on the computer like if i'm coding
the
electronics are doing something like
there there are actual physical changes
happening in the circuitry
but we don't talk about the actual
objects but that's that's i think
what this person mistook nothing
they the map for the territory
that true but but the issue here is that
they talk about
mathematical objects and there is no
such monster as a mathematical object
they're using the word object so that
they can
replace them with real objects or images
and they say okay i moved
object a from x to y
and what they're really talking about is
concepts they're not
moving objects but they think they are
and they treat them as if they are
and what is useful is to develop
technology or to do math
or to do programming for that stuff it's
useful
okay because these are concepts that are
useful in those fields they have nothing
to do
with physics physics we have to explain
real mechanisms you know
why uh pen falls to the floor and i'm
not gonna do that experiment for the
millionth time here
i got it okay you got it okay there we
go
again so we need to explain that and
that's got nothing to do with
mathematical objects okay okay
next issue uh says
uh okay says what do you think about
vid the video does the higgs boso
exist by sabine hassenfelder uh
i'll be brief on this one uh i could
i i think i need to give another uh
lecture
on uh sabine okay but uh
today we got to cut it short oh and uh
and this is what she said in that video
i
pulled it out all out but i'm just gonna
look at two things here
okay and it's uh because this is what
she was addressing
whether the higgs exists okay so the
issue was the word exists
what does it mean to say exist in
mathematics or mathematical physics
which is what sabine does
well it says uh this is what we mean
when we say quarks exist we mean that
the predictions
obtained with a hypothesis agree with
observations
and she says the same story is for time
and she goes on explaining that
and then in a follow-up video she says
more or less the same thing
to summarize the last uh square there to
summarize it briefly
something exists if it is useful to
explain
observations that's her definition their
notion
of the mathematical physicists and of
course this definition cannot be used in
science or in physics very swiss cheesy
i could i could tear that one down
absolutely it's very easy to tear down
her notion of exist but see the issue is
that they use that notion
because they don't care about physics
they care about mathematics and they
care about
you know the equations related to
mathematics and what they can describe
and measure and
so they don't care about the real
physics the objects the things and so
that's why they give you an irrational
explanation
and we say and she says that in there
she says like
well this is what we think this is what
we mean when we say that the higgs
exists
and she says well what if you have a
different definition of exist
well for that you have to go to the
philosophers
across campus you got to go somewhere
else because
they might have a different notion of
what exist means and
this is our definition this is what we
mean by exist
and they're going to stick to that even
though it's an irrational definition
they cannot defend it
but they'll they'll stick to it because
it's for their
discipline okay it's what helps them in
their world
it has nothing to do bottom line is
they're not interested they're not an
interesting definition of existence
because they're not entered because the
definition of exists relates to
qualitative
type of answers it has nothing to do
with math well they're just
interested in i think the problem with
math is they're too
uh interested in relations they're only
interested in the relations that objects
have with one another
yeah not the objects themselves yeah and
so so just in the effects
in the relations how long is the table i
don't care
what the table is how long do it is what
it does
they extract all the numbers they can
out of it and then they use the
relations for things
yeah and so what happens is they can't
give you a physical interpretation
when they give you a physical
interpretation 150
of the time of these invisible
intangible entities or mechanism
they give you an irrational explanation
well it's just a metaphor yeah no
and they say well you didn't like that
good of the philosophers they deal with
that stuff we don't deal with that we
deal with just
descriptions mathematical descriptions
and that's what they equate with science
and that's what everybody gets taught in
high school
to believe it's science it equates with
science
okay and that's where the problem is
that's why science is not
uh what all these people have been doing
for two thousand or three thousand years
science is explanation what people want
to know the common man wants to know
is you know what is gravity why does the
pen fall to the floor
and once he understands that he doesn't
care about all your math all your
equations all your measurements
that's stuff he's not interested in
that's why 99
of humanity doesn't pay attention to
physics they got bored with all this
nonsense of
black holes and big bang and all that
stuff because
well if you watch any physics person
explaining something
quote unquote explaining it's usually
like let's say giving a
an interview or something usually what
they do to sidestep things not that i
don't know if they think about it as
sidestepping not not necessarily but
essentially what it boils down to is
whenever they're trying to give any
like physics-y explanation it's usually
just kind of fun facts
like did you know the universe is seven
billion years old you're like whoa
and then you're thinking of that and
you're not and he didn't answer the
question
he just gave you these fun facts like oh
you know what happens at the edge of a
black hole
holy crap or how fast yeah you fall into
a black hole
but they tell you these these things
like they're already true
yeah like one of the one of the things i
saw was was a kid asking i think it was
neil degrasse tyson what happens when
two black holes
collide yeah like it was like a little
kid in the in the thing
and first of all he went off on the on
on all these other tangents and
and then he just goes into like time
starts bending into itself and things
like that
you just like whoa dude that's crazy
bend time
yeah yeah i can bend the clock but i've
never tried bending a second
it's very hard i tried but too too
strong for me
but it sucks because it takes all the
like reality out of
yeah because when people hear that they
say oh okay it's magic
it's essentially well no they walk away
because they said i didn't understand
squat yeah they don't understand it but
like oh [ __ ] man the
universe is mysterious it's like magic
oh wow
yeah but they take all the reality out
of the most real
uh what do you call it subject physics
is the most real subject essentially
but that's why people lost interest in a
lot of that because they listen
a little bit for a while they say okay
so the universe is 14 billion years old
okay great and they walk away they're
done you know they don't want to hear
anymore because they heard it a million
times and they say oh but we have proof
and now we confirmed it to a more
accurate value and you know people don't
care about all that stuff they say okay
it's 13 billion years old we got it
that's it that's the end of physics for
that person okay
okay another fellow says
uh can you explain the mechanism
mechanics of removing the electron from
silver halide uh when light hits the
film that was one of the questions
in the chat oh it wasn't okay well
someone asked did last time i think uh
anyways or
yeah asked it uh well let's find out
silver halide is one of the compounds
formed when silver one of the halogens
silver bromide chloride uh iodide etc
mixed with uh silver okay so
those are and they use uh typically what
they say is a pseudo
chemical notation which is a g which is
silver with x it could be any one of
those compounds
okay when absorbed by uh a crystal a
uh bromide or whatever crystal photons
cause
electrons to be promoted to a conduction
band what does that mean well it means
that
um when you have a light
this is more or less compton's effect
it's more or less
uh the photoelectric effect that's more
or less what it is what is it
light hits a film in in the case of
photoelectric effect it's uh
metal here we're talking about a motion
that has
little crystals of bromide or chloride
whatever are these
uh crystals in this emulsion and what it
does
it um according to quantum okay so
this is the quantum version first okay
it supposedly hits an electron bead
remember the
quantum atom is a little um
proton we're going to go with a simple
one the hydrogen atom
it's a proton that's got a little
electron going around okay
so it hits that electron somehow it's
got very good
uh accuracy very good precision hits
that little
that found it sniped it yeah it hits it
out of its orbital puts it into
conduction band
in the case of more complex uh atoms
such as
uh iron uh it'll hit one of the
ones on the outside and hits it into the
conduction band what does it mean
means that the electron now is free to
move around the
film or the emulsion in this case okay
and so it moves around what happens the
film this emotion is not completely
uh uniform it's not uh
perfect film it's got these uh crevices
and uh indentations and so on and this
electron bead
apparently according to quantum right
falls in there or
gets stuck in there and then another
electron because remember the light is
hitting all these electrons
then another one gets stuck another one
gets stuck there another one what
happens it builds a little
uh seed okay and from that seed it grows
it grows grows
and you create this tiny film that
somehow can reflect light better
okay and that's why these photographic
films have this
material in there because it's a
material that is
um amenable to forming seeds
which grow and then can reflect light
better and that's why you get a better
image from you know these types of
materials
okay so what i can do is give you now
the brief version
okay and uh so i want to compare
first let's go with this this is the
version
that another guy has of how this of what
i just explained
essentially uh you have that uh the
crystals there the little circles then
and they're in this emulsion light comes
in there that yellow thing that's
uh light hitting it okay high frequency
light
it hits the electron which jumps out
okay of
uh its atom and they accumulate
where you see those um we call them
those uh
lightning uh bolts okay so those are
imperfections in the film
so they accumulate there as you can see
on that uh
left hand on the right hand side there
in the middle
okay they accumulate there and once they
accumulate they form the seed and from
there what you have
is uh an ever-growing region where you
have
high reflectivity okay so that's that's
in general terms the mechanism that uh
that happens during this halide thing
okay so we're shining
light on a hat on a silver halide
uh emulsion to make it shinier yeah and
you make it shinier by
the explanation quantum explanation is
you're hitting the electrons
we have a layer of electrons which
reflect
light well what happens no what happens
is the electrons bunch up there and
supposedly
they get because they're negative they
attract ions
okay so they recombine okay and they
form these
atoms these regions where there are a
lot of recombination of atoms of the
right kind of atoms
and they form this reflected film in
there that's essentially it
but we're not interested in the
technology so i'm not going to go into
technology we're interested in the
mechanism which is essentially what this
person asks here they want to know the
mechanism
okay in science we don't care about
technology we care about the mechanisms
that's what we try to explain
okay for this you have to understand
again uh here's the photoelectric effect
for which einstein won his nobel prize
in 1921 he
was able to explain it using um
what's his name um
we're gonna see the guy at the turn of
the century i'm getting old yeah
um okay i'll remember his name in a
second here photoelectric effect what is
it you have light shining on a metal
film
uh polished metal film and the electrons
start flying out okay
and the electrons flying out that forms
a current okay
flying out or along the well along the
metal so
this is a very simple simplified version
but the point is
electro uh photons coming in
hit electrons and the electrons start
flowing it's a current and that's why
when you shine light on a polished metal
film you create
you know a uh yeah i was thinking of
plank
max blank sorry okay so that's
that's more or less what's happening
here in general terms okay
so uh uh here i'm to show
the compton effect which is almost
identical in fact i think it's the same
mechanism
what is the compliment effect again you
have light coming in
hitting a film of some kind doesn't
matter we're not interested in
technology
it's a film and what happens is on the
one hand you have current
and on the other you have light coming
out
but light comes in with high frequency
because those balls
quantum hit something solid like an
electron
it loses energy frequency and so
the electrons form current in one
direction and in the other direction
what you have
is light coming out at a lower frequency
that's a competitive basically kind of
like a newton's cradle it hits the ball
at a certain speed this one slows down
gives it to this one more or less like
that okay and in one direction you have
light
at a lower frequency right than the one
that came in
another because
another photon it shoots out the back so
if you shoot light here
a lower frequency photon is supposedly
shooting out
yeah and here you'll see it and and here
you'll see a comparison a side by side
comparison
of the compton effect which i explained
the other day but it's more or less what
this person
is asking in others what is the
mechanism from the point of view
of the rope model versus quantum
mechanics so we compare them side by
side so we get an idea here okay
and here it is the one on the left is
the quantum okay
and what you have is coming in those
yellow balls that you see on the left
hand side
uh that's light coming in those are
photons and you can replace those with
waves if you want uh
what is a transverse wave so it doesn't
matter what we have is light coming in
it hits the atom what does it do it
strikes
a an electron and it moves it to the
conduction
band what does that mean it means the
electron is free to flow
when you have lots of light coming in
hitting lots of electrons what you have
is
an electron current that flows but
because the light coming in had high
frequency and hit
an electron what you have coming out is
a low
frequency light or long wavelength light
what is the mechanism under the rope
model uh in comparison just side by side
comparison there
we don't have light coming in in the
sense that something hits
the electrons what you have is the
torsion
of the ropes so i put one rope there but
you have to think of that as gazillions
of ropes
uh stuck to gazillions of atoms that
form the
film that you're hitting light against
okay so to speak
and what it does because the torsion is
at a high frequency
it compels the uh merged electron
shells that form the film
to torque as well to rotate
that rotation is what we call
electricity current
whatever name you want to give it
rotating electron shells
yeah and then what you have in another
direction is light but light because
it it was stopped by the effort that the
ropes
expended in moving the film
the light coming out comes at a lower
frequency or
longer wavelength so the torque comes in
spins the atoms
electron shell around the atoms yeah and
the electron shells
remember the electrons chosen right but
the
electron cells remember are merged okay
so they're burnt
okay so they're they're also aligned etc
and what you've got coming out is
lower frequency or higher uh
link length as we call it uh think of it
as wavelength if you want
coming out there's a lot of spinning
involved there yeah so
that's the comparison do you believe in
it that's your problem
okay we we explain so that you
understand the difference
what you conclude is your own the gripe
that i have with that oh
there's a right yeah if you have many
ropes converging on one atom
if you only have one rope and one you
know ball if you spin the rope the ball
turns that makes sense but if you have
many ropes coming into one ball
and they're all spinning on their own
why would the ball
spin when just the tips of where the
the rope hits the ball spin well
remember
there although you have a row
and you have light coming towards the
row head on
so the whole row spins yeah but if you
have a ball
yeah yeah you have many ropes hitting
the ball let's say two just to make it
simple if you have two
and they're both spinning on their own
yeah why does this ball spin or not
yeah i guess the ball but i guess the
ball in this case isn't it a
ball it's a it's a well the string
well uh first of all what do you know
what i'm saying right yeah yeah one
more than likely this one spins this one
spins right but if you have two ropes
and they're
yeah they're speeding on their own why
would this one spin yeah the first thing
we have to remember is that
typically it's not atoms we're talking
really
about molecules okay so we're talking
all these atoms uh all these uh films
for example metal
you're taking a strip of iron
and all the atoms are more or less
aligned to some degree but when you hit
it with something like light they do
become aligned immediately and they're
easy
to rotate in the case of iron and some
of these
conductive films and what happens is
when you
come in there they immediately start
spinning when they hit where you when
you hit it with the
right frequency light or high frequency
light
and what he's saying is well what if you
have
gazillions of ropes and they hit the
atom not exactly in the center
but they hit them all around so you have
a like a beam
hitting the atom the first atom or the
first molecule if you wish whichever one
and you're hitting it uh all around the
electron shell
so you're not hitting it in the center
and having a spin
like you would spin maybe the little
balls that form
a um in abacus okay that you can't
pass your hand and they'll spin right
but if if you had many wires
then you say well why do they spin well
the issue here
is if this is something very hard
because another guy asked this question
we're going to get to that in a second
and that's that when the electron shell
spins
it goes right through the other rope
that's on the side
and people have problem with touch touch
and see and that's
we'll get to that in a second well i
think one big thing with the electron
shell
that that even i keep forgetting is it's
not a uh
ball it's i mean it's ball shaped but
it's a series of many threads
yeah it's essentially fluid you can
almost consider it
it's also remember those uh the the
atom is moving back and forth in
different directions along those ropes
that's one issue
the other one it's uh vibrating and it's
expanding and contracting there are
several motions to an atom
simultaneously and uh so you got to get
that it's very hard to picture believe
me it's even hard to draw
but we have to conclude that from the
moss power effect
which is non-recoiling uh atoms in a
crystal lattice uh you have vibrations
uh you have expansion and contraction
which is the uh
what is it the quantum jump okay so
there's several motions
to an atom you know and you're talking
about something extremely small we
cannot imagine how small that is little
on the rope that
is much smaller and thinner still but uh
you got to try to
be adam man and try to see if you can
get your mind into that little tiny
world
and just try to visualize it that's
that's all did the theory of the
rope model or the rope atom you could
say start off much simpler and then you
had to like
keep accepting more and more assumptions
like the mossbar fight and the
okay that has to have this motion as
well and then this motion you started
adding them on as you kind of
accepted assumptions yeah but it
but see if you have to explain certain
things you had to add this motion to the
atom
remember that uh throughout at least in
the last 400 years
you had um all these
researchers these theorists throughout
time
they had faraday and even before then
you had
uh arago in france and so on they
studied all these things
and they kept improving on the previous
generation and they said oh but this guy
was wrong we found something different
and
and they kept discovering more and more
properties
but they never zeroed out zeroed in on
the things
and the things themselves they tried to
analyze them mathematically they
described them mathematically they had
the proper equations
for the effects that these invisible
entities caused
but they never zeroed in on the entities
themselves
that's why they had to invent this wave
you know what is the way what is a
transverse wave
it's like a patchwork answer yeah yeah
whatever yeah
we we're more interested in the effects
of the
right whatever this is that we call
light we don't really care what it looks
like what it is
if you take uh james maxwell he came up
with great equations
you know uh he didn't enlighten us uh
regarding the equations the behavior but
he never figured out what was the object
that was
in there okay he was studying all this
stuff yeah and so well let me move on
here okay
um no but i'm just gonna skip a lot of
some of the
extra
explanations that i was gonna give but i
gotta skip because of time
okay uh how can light be physics if what
you call light
is math
okay i'm not sure i understand the
question but
here's my answer light is math let me
get these out of the way here
so i don't get them confused yeah here
okay so let me answer this gentlemen
uh so here's the answer uh
light has two components okay
uh or aspects i like this one is a
physical mediator
and the other one is what it does so
there's two aspects to light
i like that so we have the mediator uh
in quantum where they use the particle
or the transverse wave okay in the rope
model we have the dna like rope so
that's the mediator that's the thing
okay
and then we have what it does and in q1
quantum mechanics we have
one way straight line itinerary in the
case of
particles right and in the case of the
transverse wave we have this
up and down oscillating motion okay
which is
uh an up and down itinerary essentially
in the rope hypothesis what we have is
two-way torsion
okay and that's a little different than
quantum mechanics
okay so we have to distinguish not
not say it's math because math is just a
description
we have to find out what is the object
and what does it do
those are two different things what they
figured out what is
what it does that they had no problem
uh but they never figured out what it is
what is it and we have this issue where
they say well
light does not need listen carefully to
the wording here okay
light does not need a medium through
which
to propagate that's not the question
that's not the mathematicians are
answering the wrong question
the question is yeah light can go
through water light can go through air
light can go through vacuum through
nothing no problem there
we're not talking about the medium
through which
light can go we're talking about the
medium
that that mean that light is itself
we want to know what light is and people
say well light is nothing
well then you have the movement of
nothing because if you're saying that
light travels at 300 000 kilometers per
second
what is it that's traveling yeah yes so
forget about the
medium through which it's traveling
we're concerned about the medium of
light itself
what is light what is vibrating what is
traveling
that's the question that's the question
the mathematicians never answer
they go and answer the question nobody
asked which is uh what is the mean
it doesn't need a medium through which
to travel but that's a common one
they answer a lot of questions that you
didn't ask i didn't answer that question
question yeah but we answered it yes yes
we'll do a pro bono you can keep this
one
okay another fellow ass
i need a better system it takes time to
erase them from all the way to the
bottom
with respect to the rope hypothesis how
can torsional waves be
polarized i didn't understand the
explanation
given in the book um
i don't know what book you read but uh
nowhere
that i know i've ever written anything
about what
torsional waves in fact i specifically
state that there are no such things as
waves waves is a verb
so until you can phrase your question
in a scientific in a physical sense
i have no idea what book you read or
where you got this okay
so no we don't have torsional waves
whatever that means
i have no idea okay uh
you gotta rephrase that in a scientific
manner
okay let's move on with another issue so
we just didn't understand the question
yeah i mean i don't know what torsional
wave is i never use that in my book so i
don't know where he got that maybe you
can uh
uh quote the passage in the book so that
i know what exactly you did not
understand because you're saying you
didn't understand the torsional wave
and i don't know where you got that
because i don't understand torsional
waves either oh
got the wrong one there see shut the
dinosaur
the uh no it's the uh coin the bite coin
uh one guy has something related to link
length
okay he says the following he says
so when an atom pumps its electron shell
quantum leap right it releases a link or
wave of light
yeah if the wavelength of light is a
meter then
does that mean that the electron shell
expanded to a meter
very good question love you very good
question
finally when that is scientific okay
what that makes you think
okay i'll give you my five cent worth
and these are the things you gotta look
at
uh to zero in on that question and i'm
not saying that i've got a full answer
for that
okay i'll just give you the best answer
i got and these are the things
that you have to consider for that okay
and so let's go one by one the first one
is a visible spectrum
versus the radio frequency spectrum you
see it down at the bottom there
you can see the visible spectrum is very
tiny compared to the full spectrum
in fact i don't think it's very well set
up i think the
uh full spectrum is much longer than the
visible spectrum very small part
of the spectrum of electromagnetic
spectrum is visible
cold atoms uh pump slower okay
in fact someone asked about and i think
i've got that question there as well
someone asked about um what is it
quantum computers and they have a lot to
do with cold
you know trying to uh make something
work
under certain uh temperature conditions
okay
and all i'm saying is when you have a
cold atom okay
what you have you're producing low
frequency uh
low energy and longer wavelength which
under the rope model means that
you know well i'll show you a picture in
a minute which is you have
uh better see it here high frequency
means many links and each link is
smaller
and low frequency few links and each
link is longer
okay so that's essentially the notion of
low frequency high frequency low energy
high
energy okay that's that's the model
from the rope model from the rope
hypothesis quasars are distant
objects and they emit radio waves in
fact
originally when they detected them uh it
was through
radio waves they said what are those
things these are so far away
the farthest objects in the universe
their pinpoint
they form apparently the center of
galaxies and they emit radio waves and
that's got to do a little bit with the
red shift
the redshift means that people think in
other words the mathematician not people
mathematicians think that redshift means
that
something is receding from us
okay and that's how they determine
whether uh
the thing is coming towards us or far
away if it's coming towards us it's blue
shifted if it's going away it's red
shifted
not true not true uh the issue here
let me take that out so that we can see
your face at least right
uh i can't even see your face now let me
get that one out
what is the issue the issue is that um
if you take a rope any rope okay let's
show that
yeah you take a rope and you tie it to a
wall
and you go to the other side of the
universe okay that rope
as it goes towards you farther and
farther away from the source
okay the links will become longer
so a longer link is
a red shifted
that's how we would detect it as a red
shift and
a shorter link will detect as a blue
shifted
link it can have to do
with whether an object is approaching or
receiving for example the andromeda
galaxy is approaching us and is blue
shifted but not all
objects that come and go are red shift
and blue shift
in the case of quasars they're so far
away that
every rope that comes from a quasar to
our eyes or to our telescopes or
whatever we use a radio
detectors uh what we're detecting is an
object that is so far away that the
ropes have become
um longer uh linked
and that's why they're redshifted
and it turns out that just by sheer
co-innocence the far
the the far away objects are all
red-shifted and so what these people
have misinterpreted
is that oh that's red-shifted because
it's flying away from us
not necessarily are there any could be
but not necessarily they could be coming
towards us
but the rope is so tired
yeah it's called tired light and and
uh it's so untwined and the links are so
long
that they're red-shifted are there any
really far away galaxies that are blue
shifted
uh that's a good question and uh they
they try to match them with cp variables
but
that's a long story
they don't know because they only have
one notion right now for blue and red
shift they think it's only related to
motion does that become a problem
because they start
interpreting and also passing on
information with the interpretation that
all redshifted things
are going away so you can't really tell
is that how even how they determine
distance and uh one of the guys who
criticized that was the father who died
uh short a couple of years ago halt the
narp and he criticized
uh all that redshifted star he was an
astronomer and they kicked him out
because he said uh all these are not
redshift blueship does not just mean
motion
it could mean distance he had another
explanation than me
but the point is you can't just go with
one interpretation you got to listen to
all the
theorists out there and well you choose
the one you want it doesn't mean you're
going to silence the guy which they did
they kicked them out of the states
essentially they didn't give him any
telescope time so he had to go to
germany and
and do his stuff there but again you got
to listen to all these theories because
you know they might click something in
your mind and
and that's the value of science of
making you think and you reach your own
conclusion believe in whatever you want
you can believe in god if you want
okay uh let's move on here uh
one fellow says we'll go quickly with
these
says there are no ropes as such did you
look at the pictures you showed
no ropes well yeah you can't see the
electromagnetic ropes the
electromagnetic rope is what you use
to see okay so that's the way it works
and here i
i i've got a little uh gift here a
little
drawing and here i put five atoms one
per finger
okay and they're approaching a ball and
i'm just looking at one atom per finger
connected to one atom
of uh each of the ball right and so
as the fingers move towards the ball uh
they're sliding through the ropes that's
trippy
and so when you slide through the ropes
you can't see the rope itself it's like
it's like saying look i've got a beat on
the abacus
and the beat on the abacus is sliding
through the wire right
well does the bead ever touch the wire
uh yes it does because it's made out of
the wire in the case of
the rope model the the atom is
eating into the rope because the rope
uh the threads of the rope form part of
the atom
so the the atom touches the rope but at
the same time he can never
meet up with a rope because it's it can
only meet up with another atom further
down the road because that one it hits
again
against but it cannot hit against the
rope because it's sliding through the
rope because the rope is part of the
atom
it's uh the two threads make up the atom
hold on as a side tension
yeah crazy side tangent um does that
mean that
if you have a ball uh-huh take any
object yeah
existing like this thing let's take i
don't know whatever this pen
this pen is never made of the same
thread because over here now it's a
different set of threads
all the atoms just abacus the round and
the thread that makes those atoms
uh s snaked through slides through
that's right through
so essentially if you're moving this is
it is going it's different
part of the ropes yeah uh and
and remember something it depends on if
the
ropes are crisscrossing the universe
you know you can't move those ropes
you're sliding through them but then you
have objects which are nearby
okay and now that's a little different
okay
perhaps uh so you might have two two
situations
one where the ropes which are close by
it's like you know
you got a fishing rod okay and you got
the fish very close by in the pond
and you can pull that fish through that
rope but at the same time
if you have uh your your fishing line
going through the earth all the way to
china okay it's just crisscrossing and
you just happen to go through that rope
well then you're just sliding through
the rope
so you you can have two motions and
again this is something that needs to be
looked at in more detail okay i can't
tell you
which is the case yeah it is complicated
because you're you're talking about
something you can't see
you just have to imagine when you find
out just how it how it could be working
and so i can't give you a
straightforward answer to all these
questions i can just tell you
what to think about because you know i
can't i don't have a solution for every
little thing
but again admit that but all i can do is
give you
what goes through my mind to try to fix
to try to explain
that phenomena but it's a direct
correlation if we're assuming
that uh that all the atoms here
abacus through rope yeah then the matter
assuming we we're calling matter
the threads slash ropes then it's always
different matter
it comprises yeah yeah it's a different
it's different uh rope or different
difference
but that could be but that could be that
could be from the ropes that
are crisscrossing the universe or
or you know that that you're going
through
and then there could be other ones like
maybe the moon for example
the moon the earth spins the moon around
but what through the ropes that connect
the atom from the earth to the atom that
ends
in the atom in the moon okay that one is
uh short term that a short distance the
ones that go through
the ones that uh it goes through the
moon goes through
ropes that crisscross the universe
because they go from matter on one side
of the universe to matter on the other
side of the universe
those they go through and and those are
you know
uh more or less like um the radio
frequency the fact that
you know you in fact i did not finish
that
for lack of time but radio frequency you
know you can't have two people on the
same radio frequency
and again what what uh adam what uh
ropes are you stimulating well you could
be stimulating ropes that
uh crisscross our region that's why
they're rf they're
long wavelengths right and what happens
is
i can get on that wavelength but you
can't because if you get on that
wavelength we're both
interfering with each other because
these are the ropes that crisscross the
universe
okay maybe you can affect maybe the um
what is it the uh
the amplitude you can affect maybe the
frequency
but only one person can get on that wave
because
otherwise you know we're two people on
the same uh rope
so to speak and so these are the things
that need to be ironed out
i'm not saying that i've got an answer
to all this i'm just saying that
these are the things i think about when
i look at this and try to explain to
myself you know but the
universe under the rope model sounds
more like the matrix
yeah like this it is like like when you
see it like it's kind of when neo sees
the matrix you see all these lines
crisscrossing everywhere
yeah there you go if you could see the
ropes you you'd go insane
yeah it'd be a matrix everywhere thank
god
thank god we can't see the rope holy
[ __ ] okay and here is i know
my question uh thought says he's a
little angry at me he said my question
was not about c
touch criteria you converted into c
touch criteria
i wanted to know that when magnetic
threads spin
it doesn't what clash
clash class slash slash slash that's
what you said clash of blah blah blah
blah blah blah
i didn't complete the sentence it
doesn't yeah
why why when the rope goes
or crosses or whatever the thread he
said why don't they clash
and so yes he's talking about c touch he
doesn't even know what he's asking
okay so he is talking about seeing i
guess
this person is making a distinction
between clash and touch
and there is no difference because we
look at the definition of the word clash
yeah that's the word he used okay i'm
going to use his word
and it says clash to come together or
what
collide we're talking about dutch
they should have specified what they
mean by clash then well that's what i'm
saying you got to make your
if you you say that you're not talking
about touch
then don't use the word clash i don't
know talk about something else the word
clash is kind of synonymous with touch
yeah it is clash but he doesn't realize
that i mean
so something got lost in the translation
people don't uh
understand what they're asking yeah
you're talking about maybe he's got a
real question but
well yeah well then he's got to read
he's got to rephrase it so that
i mean if you're talking about clash
you're talking about you're saying why
doesn't the rope go the thread or the
thread through the rope or thread
through the thread or broke through the
rope
you're talking about touch and again an
object is not that which you can touch
an object is not that which you can see
so don't bring the word see touch
in any way shape or form i think it's
just sad when i see these kind of things
because it's like
there's obviously a question that they
want to ask but you know when they ask
it like that
it's like clash is touched so it'd be
nice to know what the distinction
in their mind is between clash and touch
because there's obviously something i
mean
everyone understands clashes touch okay
two more quest two more questions or
comments one person says square is
shape but it is not an object this is a
fact well we'll find out if it's a fact
once you define the word object
and you have to defend the word object
you can't say well square is a shape but
it's not an object
well if it's not an object define object
we'll know
you got to define the word and you have
to defend it you can't just put
whatever gobbledy goo comes to your mind
you got to define and
defend define and defend and then we're
over like definitions it makes
everything kind of yeah and a lot of
these people lose their religion
losing my religion they lose their
religion
with the definition of the word object
what does bill gates say the definition
of the word object destroys all religion
and that's why people are so
uncomfortable with my definition they
try to fight it
and they say well everybody else
believes in some other definition
we don't care how many people raise
their hands you gotta defend
your definition you can't defend it you
don't have a definition
and the last one here is along the same
line objects are three dimensions which
we can see
and touch and so we have a human here on
earth and we have the cling on there and
klingon land on the other side of the
universe there's a gazillion miles
between us
he's got a table is his table which you
cannot see
or touch a an object i wonder if it's an
object
right there well yeah but i can't see
the table the chinese man has on the
other side of the earth
i cannot see the table you are thinking
of
so is the word table an object a blind
man can't see any of the tables
so it's not so he doesn't see any so
there are no objects we're not a blind
man he can't see your touch
so now you got to define the word object
first before you
criticize you can't just go in there and
say well i don't like your definition
it's only because it destroys your
religion that's the only thing
i think there's a big confusion between
[Music]
that which you can see and that which is
seeable
you know like i can't i can't i cannot
see a table
yeah yeah but that's not an object it's
not a
is the word table does the word table
represent an object that's what it
that's another issue they make a synonym
but the issue is
you have to define the word object and i
know it destroys
your religion the one you had all these
years i don't care about it we have to
define it
in an examination all right then we need
we need a definition for the word object
in physics because you cannot do
physics without an object so i'm sorry
if my religion
my my definition destroys your religion
go ahead let's go with the question some
questions okay go slowly here
some people get angry if you miss them
if i'm if we miss you
i look at these anyways later on and
i'll address it next year
so don't worry you go into these and
that's where you get the next list
go ahead buffering buffering buffering
all okay buffering
uh the question we answered earlier
hopefully of um the silver
halide okay yeah silver halide
i didn't maybe complete that i'll i'll
probably complete that answer next time
um seems like you went i'm good into it
well
there were a couple details that i
missed there that i did not cover but
i'll continue with the silver halide
next time but in general terms it's
uh it's more or less the notion of
compton effect and
photoelectric effect they're all the
same thing because what they're saying
compared to quantum quantum says light
comes in
hits the halide there and knocks an
electron out
all these electrons bunch up in a crack
or whatever
and because they have all this
negativity it
attracts ions and by doing so you have
the seed that builds up and creates this
film but that's the quantum version our
version is
again you know there is no
hitting there is no striking there is no
little particle that comes in and bangs
against another particle
what you have is torsion and the torsion
moves
the uh atoms which are all merged
really molecules because you're building
molecules in a film
but think of them as atoms no problem
just to get the notion
what you have is all these merged atoms
these electron shells
they spin and what you have in another
direction
is you know a low frequency light
and that's essentially the mechanism the
difference between quantum men
and the rope hi bill i don't follow the
casual chain
of your theory of man's extinction how
does the
decreasing genetic diversity and
population
lead man through his own policies to
destroy his economy
uh just in a nutshell what we're having
is when you have less population okay
let's get this straight less population
means
less demand all companies all companies
they expect more demand next year they
expect
uh more and more sales growth growth and
growth ultimately is population more
population
no problem there's more demand next year
next year more populations that need
things
yeah and what happens when population
starts declining
population growth yeah or population
starts slowing down first and then
declining sounds like they're dying off
no no it is because that's what's
happening at some point the old people
have to die
and then what you have is more people
die because they've already seized old
ages
we haven't produced new people new young
people to fill in the vacuum
and that's when you approach zero
population growth known as epg
and when you approach cpg it means you
approach
population wise demographically wide
right
when you approach the asymptote okay
you're growing
asymptotically well then demand
starts slowing down and the companies
now
next year don't have as much pull from
demand
remember our human economy is an
inverted population
pyramid scheme okay you have it like
that and we expect more and more growth
eventually but what happens when that
turns into
you know what we're seeing it across the
unit the planet and that's this you know
slowly the population pyramid is
inverting
when that happens you have less demand
and when you have less demand
a lot of companies close down they merge
they
they uh they sell less the you get rid
of the competition you get into
monopolies
and what happens you have to kick people
out
of their jobs especially if you
introduce in conjunction with that you
introduce
efficiency meaning robots or whatever if
you make things more efficient uh that
only takes more people out you have
uh yeah and so what happens people will
work for less
we'll work for food and at some point
you you're working you don't even get
food
and so at that point you know we have a
problem with the
inversion of the ecological pyramid
because at some point
people has have no purpose to go to work
because they don't make enough money to
make at the end of the month to pay
their rent to pay their food
so the guy you know said why am i going
to work instead i think i'll go outside
with a crowbar and start breaking
windows
and i think that's what's going to be
happening in the next few years
is psychiatry or economic science
yeah psychiatry and what's your economy
economics
there's science uh if you're gonna
explain if you explain
something you're doing science if you're
doing descriptions
mathematics you're not doing science uh
description is not science
mathematics was not built for science
mathematics just describes you measure
you
get an equation and you described and
what have we learned well i guess it
depends you can break either of these
down into religion or science because
we're talking about economics
you could be talking about explaining
why the depression happened
that would be science okay but giving a
recommendation on what to do with your
money is also economics but
recommendation is not science
recommendation religion that's what i'm
saying either of these psychiatry
could be explaining why the person
killed someone what you're saying
whereas psychiatry could also be what i
recommend
you do is you work out you eat
right so that you can think right yeah a
recommendation is religion whereas
explaining something
because these could be branches of the
past or the future it could be economics
what happened or economics what you
should do
yeah and again i want to distinguish
between a recommendation
politics all that religion belief that's
different than explaining something
here we're talking about mechanisms if
you're explaining something
in economics of why something happens
what caused something to happen
then you're doing history same thing
it's it's it's
science if you can explain why napoleon
went to waterloo
you're doing science if you just state
that napoleon did go to waterloo well
you're not doing science well i guess
the one time where you break that rule
is when you're talking about human
extinction because that hasn't happened
yet
and i explained that in the past we're
not going to get into that one but
i'm just saying i'll kill you later on
um i mean there was a debate here so i
guess i'll just turn into a question
are are words objects no of course not
words are not objects well it depends
because again the debate goes into
saying well the air that i'm moving
now let's put in the right context okay
let's put in the right context
you go to the dictionary and there's
only two types of words
you have words that represent objects
because they
have shape or they represent things that
have
shape table chair tree
those are all the word represents an
object the fact that we use uh certain
letters and in different languages we
have different letters
no problem the point is that that word
represents an object
there are other words that represent
concepts and those are
those that which do not have shape
primarily
but the definition of concept is a
relation
okay it's a a word that invokes two
objects so object has shape and
concept two objects that's essentially
in a nutshell
that question means you say light is
torque of a rope
in that question light be physics if
light is math
if like if light is i don't understand
it
no light again light is math
targets no but no
torque is a verb torque is what the
light does we need to find out first
what is light in this case the rope
in the case of quantum it's particles uh
waves
which are just a bunch of vectors but
particles for sure that's
but it turns out that even in that case
the particle is not a particle
they're not talking about corpuscles
again they're talking about equations
etc
but assuming if we go to classical
mechanics we're talking about corpuscles
which is what newton had in mind and
we're talking about you know all these
particles
that are moving and that's the object
fine we all understand that a stream of
particles that's
the object that mediates light what is
light
the rectilinear propagation of all those
particles
in the case of rope the rope is the
object this is the object
but if i just show you a robe and just
make it stand still
we don't have light all we have is a
rope in order to have light you need to
have a torque
so we have to distinguish torsion from
rope rope is the object torsion is what
it does
the light is the verb that the plus the
object oh yeah
the object is kind of weird trying to
distinguish
the object from its motion yeah but
uh you got to put them together and you
can say that the math part
the mathematics part is the 300 000
kilometers
per second there's something moving
there but what is moving well it's a
torsion
of what of a physical object called a
rope or a rope like
making a thing and it's a dna rope-like
thing
well we ever see bill in a t-shirt with
funny picture
uh yeah i was like that in uh in
iceland uh
i butchered someone's question arthur
why
am i talking about oh how does the
decreasing genetic diversity
and population lead man through his own
policies and to
destroy his economy well i already said
that yeah okay but that was the question
okay yeah essentially there it's uh
what you have is you need more demand
next year and right now
what we're not producing is future
demand
where our population growth is slowing
down
and just to give you a number we had 2.3
1963 that was our
global population growth rate today
we're
down to one and by mid-century it's
scheduled to go to zero or close to zero
anywhere from mid-century to the end of
the century
but those are projections from the
mathematicians the demographers
they just calculate i mean i don't even
know how much population there's going
to be
2030. there's a lot of variables yeah i
mean we don't have uh
if an asteroid hits the earth and kills
uh
it kills all the chinese where he said
well we lost a billion people so how do
how can we predict what's going to be
the population the year 2030.
there's no way you can predict that all
they do is project
trends and they say well we think that
by mid-century there's gonna be so much
but they don't know that
if if girls i mean i've been asking girl
a lot of the girls
uh that i see out there informal right
it's an informal
poll a lot of them don't want to have
kids they don't want to have kids
in the cities they say no no i don't
have time i don't have money
uh i want my freedom etc etc they don't
have kids
and so you know we're not going to have
what we need to replace the population
2.2 approximately has been calculated by
the demographers
you need 2.2 kids per couple right now
we're not even having we're having one
right now and i don't know what we're
gonna have in the future half
half a baby
um any thoughts on the great reset
uh yeah it's it's just uh
what we're having is is uh just a glitch
that's all it is
it's it's a we're not making anything
substantial
okay there's nothing really profound any
more than there was when we had
recessions or depression
the 1929 famous depression
these are these are recent they were
resets okay we have
resets every now and then whenever we
have a depression or recession
but does that change anything does that
change our culture does it change our
economic
our global economic structure it doesn't
i mean you know i want you to think
about something i was thinking about
today
you have north korea okay communist
country you have cuba communist country
why do they need to trade
internationally
i mean you would think that these
countries they should be self-sufficient
they don't need the u.s
why are they worried for example uh cuba
why is cuba worried for the last 70
years
why is cuba worried about um having this
uh commercial blockade from the u.s why
does it worry say okay you guys want a
blockade you want to put a
um a wall around us we don't care we're
self-sufficient
why don't they say that well because no
country
in the world including communist
countries are not self-sufficient
they need to trade and whatever hurts
their trade international trade hurts
them big time
in the case of north korea well they go
through the
through the little channel there and
talk to the chinese the chinese are
supporting the
north koreans without china korea north
korea
is nothing it would collapse tomorrow
the recommendation is not opinion
it is recommendations opinion religions
known as religion anytime you have
opinion uh recommendation belief you're
doing religion
nothing to do with science uh your
assumption is light is
torque of a rope therefore light is math
is this physics how i think there are
the physic here's the physics part the
the physics part is the object okay in
this case the rope
or whatever it's a rope-like entity
that's what we're proposing
that's a physical object what it does
which is torsion
that's the verb so you have and that's
so the physics part is the rope
and the you could say the math part is
the velocity of torsion
bill i meant to ask how does the rope
torquing
light result in polarized unpolarized
circularly polarized etc light
how does polarizing filter block
torquing
i've got that okay that's
uh i've got it in one
yeah it's a little complex and and again
what it is is a a picture is worth a
thousand words
i have a i'll address that question
next time now that you talk about rope
instead of wave
okay i'll address that question next
time i'm going to show you a picture
of how polarization is done i think i
have a good grasp on polarization okay
and essentially is that um when well i'd
have to explain again it's
a picture's worth a thousand words one
picture you look at it you say okay i
understand
so i'll show that next time take a rain
check please
uh wind is when the air moves light is
when the rope torques
what is there not to understand okay
he's answering the other person light is
something we can't see but it's a rope
or
torque is light the rope or a torque of
the rope yeah
all of the above you'll be cheating it's
a b and c well i guess the effect of
light is the torque of the rope
when when the bump hits the end of
whatever our eye
because it because it's uh imagine this
is the atom
i'm going to put my fist here and this
is the rope right
ending at the atom it doesn't really end
remember one thread goes around the
other one is through but
this is the issue the circle you you you
you just take a rope
and twirl it against your hand and
you'll you're going to feel something
there there is a
put your hand uh yeah do you feel
something no
okay so so you're you're moving
something
at the surface of the atom which is the
electron
shell okay the electron membrane i don't
know you what to call it that's where
the effect the balloon
comes out yeah and so you're it's like
if you've got
a rope tied to your balloon and you
twist it the rubber balloon you twist it
well the rubber is going to feel
something there's going to be some
change at the surface
right and that's the point here the
point is that there is that little
friction and that's
uh the the uh aggregate of that around
the electron shield is what we call
charge
did cuba slash iran benefit from from
your pentium leagues
uh i think it's it's not cuba
uh iran probably a little bit uh i think
it was mainly the russians
the russians did get and and east
germans uh
they took advantage of that quite a bit
and i know that for a fact
essentially yeah i'll just give you a
little bit there
um when i went to cuba i went to cuba
several times
and i was in pinar del rio which is on
the west side of the
country and that's where they have their
uh chip
plant well it was uh a
very basic chip plant um
they had very old for for what i studied
you know i had very old equipment
the second time i went to cuba uh they
had given
the information to the soviets in those
days
there was no russia it was soviet union
and the soviets
gave machinery for free in exchange for
the information to the cubans
when i got there i saw the machines with
my own eyes i touched them okay
and they had implanters and they had
aligners
and you can look up what those things
are an implanter is a
small accelerator ion accelerator and
they have these machines worth
maybe two three million dollars that
were given
for free to the cubans in exchange for
the information
you tell me if the russians got
something out of that
they had to get something free to give
two three million dollars away
is the sun a rope the set is not a road
there's a sense before that what is but
what is light
i see the sun and i think light as its
synonym
the sun is a rope well the sun is not a
robe
uh an atom in the sun is tied to an atom
in your eye
okay let's assume you could look
straight at the sun
okay well that atom that you can see
there
if you're atom man right is connected to
an atom in your eye
and of course we get tons of these
gazillions of these
ropes tied to gazillions of atom that
form your eye
and that's what we can see because we're
seeing it hopefully you're seeing
through a medium
this notion that light is not mediated
by an object that's what's
that's when you introduce black magic
hopefully
whenever you see you're seeing through a
physical mechanism
that you cannot see or touch yeah
it gets a little complicated yes we're
trying to talk about seeing
light yeah you can see that how can i
see the rope that's coming straight into
my eye which is what
torques and gives me light allows me to
see i guess the other way of saying is
there's no way to not see it
because that is all we see yeah
if you think about it all we see is
light well you see another atom
down the road because it's in the right
frequency that's torquing
and reaching your eye but we cannot see
for example the air because it's outside
the
visible range that's the only reason we
can't see the air fortunately
if we could see the air we'd be in
trouble because that's all we would see
that's all we would see all day long
we'd all be blind that's it
okay well folks we'll see you next time
on sunday something wasn't answered
uh yeah okay i do have an answer but
it's a little more complex i'll explain
a little
more about um polarization go down the
list
yeah yeah i'm going to copy then answer
the man
okay we'll see you then on sunday